قال ان ثمانية صواريخ اصابت
المدينة ودعا السكان الى البقاء
في الملاجئ. زالنيسكي روسيا لا
تفهم الا لغة القوة. لاول مرة
التوقعات ابقى تحالف اوبك بلس
على الالتزام بزيادة الانتاج
لوجانسك والدونيسك. الخزانة
الامريكية واشنطن وحلفاؤها
جمادوا اصولا روسية بقيمة
ثلاثمائة وثلاثين مليار دولار.
ينسوا شهداءهم الذين وصل عددهم
لاكثر من مليون فهل يعي
منذ السبعينات دولة الوقود عن
مواطنيها وهو ما فعلته سيريلانكا
الحلف يمر باقصى في تاريخه جراء
تداعيات الحرب الاوكرانية.
انضمام السويد وفنلندا الى
الناتو وهل ستحصل تركيا على
تصدير المنتجات كما هو ابداء
لحسن نيتنا. القوات الاوكرانية
خلال عام ودول البلطيق والبلقان
مهددة. اثارت تصريحات النائب في
الفرنسيين لتلك الفترة لكن
الجزائريين والعرب عموما لم
بريطانيا تتزايد لاوكرانيا
ومليار جنيه استرليني مساعدة
تتدرب في بريطانيا على انظمة
الصواريخ المتطورة. مساعدات
بعد دعم ادارة بايدن لصفقة بيع
محتملة مع تركيا تزود فيها انقرة
بمنع الوقود عن مواطنيها لعدم
توفر العملة الصعبة لشرائه?
وثمانية واربعين الف برميل يوميا
خلال اغسطس المقبل. عمدة نيكولاي
الروسي في مواجهة الناتو والغرب
مكاسب تركية. بعد ان منع بيعها
التركية رغم عزم بايدن على تنفيذ
الصفقة لكن لا صفقة اسلحة تتم
بالجوانب العسكرية ليكونا
التحالفا ضد التحالف الغربي.
بدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا في حربها
ضد روسيا. في قرار متوافقا مع
بايدن الناتو سيصبح اقوى بانضمام
فنلندا والسويد. ماكرون نطالب
البحر الاسود وموسكو ترد
انسحابنا من جزيرة الافعى لتسهيل
لتركيا. ها هي تركيا تقترب من
الحصول على طائرات اف ستة عشر
موافقة الكونجرس فهل تعد هذه
الصفقة جزءا من موافقة انقرة على
ورعب يلوح في الافق. الجميع يعرف
اين تبدأ الحرب لكن لا احد يعرف
اسوأ في مدريد تعلن قمة الحلف
رفع العتاد العسكري الى سبعة
الجديدة تجاه الصين وروسيا
والعسكريون يصرحون النفط يرتفع
مسؤولية الكارثة الانسانية وازمة
الطاقة فهل العالم على ابواب
اضعاف وفي قمة ميونخ تبلغ مجموعة
السبعة الاوكراني انها سترسل
الروسية في جزيرة الافعى
بالمدافع والصواريخ. بعد ذلك
الابيض والكونجرس. نذر مواجهات
تقترب بين روسيا والناتو. الحلف
بوتين بالمثل بقوله سنخلق نفس
التهديدات في حال نشر قوات
صواريخ ناسامز المضادة للطائرات
التي تحمي بها امريكا البيت
عسكرية في فنلندا والسويد. وعلى
خطى بكين حذر بوتين من علم احادي
القطب. موضحا خطورة هيمنة دولة
واحدة على العالم. واكد ان عملية
يعسكر اوروبا على ابواب روسيا
وامريكا تتوسع في اوروبا وتزيد
اضافية من لندن للدعم العسكري
لكييت. الامين العام لحلف الناتو
زيلانسكي يعلن قطع العلاقات مع
سوريا بعد اعترافها بجمهوريتي
الدخول ام انها ستكسر الابواب
وتدخل? ام ستعود من عند عتبة
النفطي مثلما كان مقررا في
اجتماعه السابق بواقع ستمائة
الحرب العالمية الثالثة على
الابواب فهل تطرق الابواب قبل
وانما ساطلب ذلك من كل دول
الخليج. اولم تسمع يا بايدن ما
على الرئيس الامريكي هل ستطلب من
السعودية زيادة انتاج النفط? رد
بايدن يتحدث عن زيارته المقبلة
للخليج. طرح احد الصحفيين سؤالا
الحرب العالمية الثالثة? هل بدأت
الحرب? الناتو يكشف استراتيجيته
عدد القوات الامريكية نحو مائة
الف جندي موزع في اوروبا وبالقرب
الخليجيين بانتظار الرد الخليجي
يا اصدقاء. نذر الحرب العالمية.
العالمي. واضافت الوزارة الصينية
ان الناتو يشجع على عودة الحرب
قاله لك الرئيس الفرنسي لكن مهلا
هل سيستطيع بايدن تغيير قرار
امريكا تنوي منح كييب مساعدات
مالية وعسكرية لشراء منظوم
الباردة. الحرب هي مقبلات فقط
لحرب عالمية كبرى. بايدن ونفط
السعودية والامارات لا تستطيعان
زيادة انتاج النفط واليوم خرج
اعلن مدير مكتب زالنسكي ان
القوات الروسية اخلت جزيرة على
الفرنسيون ذلك؟ وسائل اعلام
اوكراني. اوكرانيا تستهدف القوات
بعد حديثه عن الفترة الاستعمارية
لفرنسا في الجزائر وحنين
البرلمان الفرنسي خوسيغونزاليس
غضبا واسعا عبر منصات التواصل
الصفقة حقا؟ الاحداث والتطورات.
زالنسكي بوتين قد يغزو اوروبا
يا بوتين. هجمة مرتدة. هجمة
مرتدة نفذتها الصين وروسيا مع ضد
بلاده في اوكرانيا تحقق اهدافها.
بينما كان الناتو قد حمل موسكو
والاسواق العالمية تهتز تحركات
لحلف الناتو توحي بان القادم
وارض المعركة هي الفيصل. فهل
يفعلها التنين الصيني مع الدب
بطائرات حربية امريكية وتحديث
الطائرات الحربية الحالية
من روسيا بعد ان كانت الفا قبل
الحرب الاوكرانية. وهناك هدد
اليه المال والسلاح. وموسكو تظهر
صور مقرات الحكومة الامريكية
اين وكيف ستنتهي. الصين وروسيا
يمكن ان يكمل كلا منهما الاخر
لاذعة للحلف بعد اعلانه ان بكين
تشكل تهديدات خطيرة للاستقرار
الخليج. الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون
اخبر نظيره الامريكي بايدن ان
ذات مرة البدء بعملية عسكرية ضد
الارجنتين. وهنا كان الرد قاسيا
فعلت تاتشر رئيسة الوزراء
البريطانية السابقة التي قررت
امام الروس بهذه المساعدات؟
بينما تلتزم اوبك بلس بزيادة
عن المواطنين في العصر الحديث.
فما هي المشكلة? الحرب كلامية.
انتاج النفط وفرنسا الى عودة
استعمارها للجزائر فهل جننتم
ايها الفرنسيون? هل نسيتم اكثر
من مليون شهيد? بريطانيا تعلن
حال. كما نصحهم بوتين بالتوقف عن
شرب الكحول. اما رئيس الوزراء
فكيف سينقشع هذا الضباب. بايدن
يقول لن اطلب من السعودية زيادة
ما ارادوا خلع ملابسهم حتى الخصر
او اقل من ذلك في تلميح جنسي ورد
مفحم عموما يبدو ان ذلك سيكون
مشهدا مثيرا للاشمئزاز على اية
تدريب الاوكران على اراضيها
وسريلانكا اول دولة تمنع الوقود
انتاج النفط. وانما ساطلب ذلك من
جميع الدول الخليجية. واشنطن
مدريد التي وصفت روسيا تهديدا
مباشرا والصين تحديا ممنهجا.
حلف الناتو واستراتيجيته الجديدة
المعلن عنها مؤخرا خلال قمة
من وجودها العسكري. استعداد للرد
على اي تهديد روسي محتمل. يبلغ
بكين رفضت محاولات تشويه سمعتها.
والخارجية الصينية وجهت انتقادات
بايدن كان غريبا. وقال لن نطلب
من السعودية زيادة انتاج النفط
استرليني دعما جديدا من لندن الى
كييف. فهل يريد الانجليز الوقوف
ذكورية بوتين. وبوتين يرد
بتلميحات جنسية. منظومة الدفاع
تحركاتكم. هكذا قالها بوتين في
حين تجتمع الصين وروسيا في حلف
حرب كلامية ساخرة بين الرئيس
الروسي وقادة الغرب قادة مجموعة
واحد امام الناتو. المسلسل
الهزلي يستمر جونسون ينتقد
حربا ذكورية وحشية على اوكرانيا.
بوتين رد على جونسون وذكره بما
سبع في نوبة ضحك يسخرون بوتين
ويقولون انهم سيخلعون قمصانهم
ليصبحوا اقوياء كبوتن. وهنا جاء
رد سريع من بوتين. لا اعرف اذا
البريطاني وفي تصريح غريب له قال
ان بوتين لو كان امرأة لما شن
استراتيجيتكم الجديدة مردودة
عليكم وسنرد بالمثل على
تعود لبيع الاسلحة لتركيا. فما
هي خبايا هذه الصفقة؟ مليار جنيه
الجوي للبيت الابيض في اوكرانيا
ونظر الحرب تزيد الوضع قتامة.
الباب وهذا ما تأمله الكرة
الارضية باسرها? فهل يحدث ذلك?